[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special
episode of GameSpot of Thrones gamespot
show that all about the wonderful world
of Westeros I'm Lucy I'm Dave and a
brand new trailer for season six of Game
of Thrones dropped yesterday so we've
been over it with a fine-tooth comb to
basically point out all the stuff that
you may have missed on your first second
or even third watch and believe me
they've packed so much into this trailer
let's get started but before we do
there's going to be spoilers first all
five seasons of the show maybe
potentially season six if we get our
predictions right and also all the books
so far so be warned okay but let's let's
go through this thing so here we are at
the wall and this is clearly basically
just picking up where we left off at the
end of season five so Jon Snow been
killed presumably traitress Holly
traitorous ollie so he's been the
brothers have turned on him I throw a
bunch of traitors we've also seen more
of this clip so if you saw on Conan
O'Brien liam Cunningham who plays Davos
Seaworth was on and he had a special
clip and it is basically how this scene
plays out in that you have the members
of the Brotherhood of the the Nights
Watch against we have a divorce ghost
the dead body of Jon Snow is he dead I'm
just going to point out the guy in the
middle because I'm getting real Benjen
vibes from him I don't know how that
would happen what do you think he was
mentioned well Ollie said the way to get
John out was to say benjin can you trust
anything all he says maybe was it was a
lie did is was he actually on his way I
mean it's possible he was lost north of
the wall but me now we've seen people
survive out there so no more on that in
a bit because we've got an amazing
character come back who was presumed
lost beyond the wall so interested to
see how the rest of that scene plays out
I thought he was the man to lead us
through John I'm gonna rewind a little
bit John looks pretty dead and I know
everyone saying and you know we've all
been on Harrington hair watch we've been
hoping that John's been alive he does
look pretty dead that in hearing the
voice over so this is tormund Giantsbane
saying I thought he was the man to lead
us through the long night but
was wrong this could be one or two
people so this could be a red herring
this could be it could actually mean
John and the prophecy that he is this
legendary Prince as or a high reborn and
he was going to lead them to the long
night and protect the men of Westeros
against all the whites and the White
Walkers could also be Mance Rayder yeah
uh who obviously died in series five
ironically at the hand of John yeah sort
of I mean he you know no I mercy killing
and anything dad the final blow so
that's quite interesting so there's
torment still got the beard so it looks
like through looks here like the
wildlings are mobilizing for war which
is a thing to bear in mind hell is wrong
here we are have the pyramids of Marine
marine where all the Khaleesi admin goes
down but as you can see here all the
high masters are kind of freaking out
while they're trying to regain control
of the city now the dinero's is vanished
so the end of season 5 drogon picked her
up and just took her out into the
grasslands of s or somewhere Tyrion as
you can see you sort of been left in
charge um he's good at that yeah he's
been anything exactly I think I think if
anyone was going to be left in charge it
would have been Tyrion um so you can
hear the voice over do you like games
little man and it sounds like Ramsey um
let me shoot player girl let's replay
look at games little man it that does
sound like right does sound a lot like
Ramsey but it could be interesting to
see if it's actually tearing that he is
referring to or a young young man you
would call a young man little man I
guess be interesting to see what I comes
up with
we would so here I mean it's it's pretty
obvious from the next shot who this is
but it's someone grabbing a dagger with
that left hand so it must be Jamie right
obviously because of the but there is a
high Sparrow you would spill blood in
this holy place so Cersei obviously
she's coming right off the back of her
humiliation she's been stripped naked
walk through the streets of King's
Landing so now the Jamie's back there he
is looking very fine and daddy were some
payback she's gonna use her brother to
sort of exact some revenge upon the
faith even though it was her fault yeah
it was very much her chickens coming
home to roost okay I don't think so
she's one to take that standing No so
you would spill blood in this holy place
and this is this is quite a nice quote
from Jamie similarly pay the rest of us
combined oh so you know strong words
against the gods there so this scene
here so this is highly likely to be some
kind of red priestess and we see later
on in the trailer there is a new one hmm
so everyone's go on these days
Melisandre obviously is going to be an
epic this looks like a new red priestess
looking into the fire for help this is
Cal saw that definite is so this is the
cows are that we assume is Cal Jacko so
Jacko if your book reader I think he's
on the show too so when Drago gets sick
he sort of immediately turns against him
he immediately turns against his cowl
and tries to take over so this is
actually his his khalasar that De Niro
sorta gets dropped off with
Oh who's that drogon drogon we have fun
this is actually kind of hard to see HBO
releases videos in 720p so this is a
real zoom and enhance thing this is
basically the weirwood uh so we can see
here this is bran and we didn't see any
of in the last season some would say
that's a good thing no I'm my brand
story line gets a bit boring for me at
times so this is the part of the story a
brand kinda comes into his own so we
know that he can walk he's walked in to
hold always walked into summer but this
is him going beyond the wall to find
like the source of all that and like
follow the three-eyed crow / Raven they
change it for the show in his dreams so
he's gone beyond the walls canna find
the source of all his powers sobran I
don't want to spoil too much for the
books but he does go on an interesting
journey of self-discovery and this is
came to the place that it starts so this
is him in the way I would know so here
you can hear in the voice-over you got
jack n Hagar the assassin from the
Faceless Man saying who are you and you
can hear are you saying no one and then
she gets smacked in the face by who I
assume it's kind of difficult to tell by
assume that's the wife yeah so the way
fizz in it and still being a bully mmm
that was a recurring theme from last
season that she hadn't kind of earned
the title of no one yet yeah which is
difficult because everyone's are no one
hey hey so this is where I think the
nurse is going to end up so in Dothraki
culture Khaleesi wives of cars when the
cars die they are made to go to vase
doth rack I hope I pronounced that
correctly which is kind of the Dothraki
they are the only have one city and it's
a sacred city because they are obviously
kind of nomadic lifestyle they roam
around on horses this is there one city
and this is where all of the the kelis
ease go once the
husbands have died so now that Daenerys
has kind of been picked up by the
Dothraki it's likely that she's put
there and you can see it being stripped
by it kind of meant to be like holy
women hmm and they called the dosh
colleen lets people a second chance so
Jack in here saying a girl has been
given a second chance so if we assume
that are you killing Sam Meryn Trant
when she wasn't supposed to was her
first chance yeah what would be sure she
must do something else that this is her
second chance I don't this is her second
chances a life I guess because she's
been made blind by the faceless man so
this is her second chance as you can't
mess up they were look at out so there's
Jack and saying there will not be a
third so you can see here by this still
she is still blind yep um so she hasn't
regained her sight uh yet yet she's so
good I guess if it's done by magic then
what she could just be daredevil via
third that's true Sansa God she looks
like she's just sick of everything at
this point she has been through so much
but what's interesting to note is on her
chest the Starks in chill so it's
interest you see that she's kind of
taken back the name Santa stock and this
is actually interesting we will this
plays in a little bit later I think
about all i think about she says um it's
all I think about what was taken from me
so you get to see kind of like you know
how aya has the list of people she wants
to kill this next bit of the trailer
kind of runs like the people that Sansa
wants to kill so Ramsay I'm this is
quite interesting I saw someone on the
subreddit picked on this he's cleaning a
blade with a cloth so he's not he's not
sharpening a blade he's cleaning it so
who was he just killed I haven't seen
his dad and he isn't in this whole
trailer that's that's that's true I mean
although he is a murderous bastard he
could have killed any number of people
but Ramsay is a bastard no longer
because Ruth root legitimized him so if
he killed him the sole heir
which I'm just saying so this is samson
hit list obviously starting with Ramsey
obviously I self Walder Frey but now
that would be a big one so Walder Frey
obviously you know sort of spearheaded
the red wedding yeah they took bread and
salt did my dad Walder he had them all
killed so he had a brother rob his wife
and her mother killed but what's
interesting to note here is these guys
in the hole all wearing Lannister armor
so why are the Lannisters in the phrase
teaming up again why's everyone now the
fray seems to be on everyone's and no
one's team so just in it for himself
where there's no one is on his deep
sorry I was lord of the rings let's not
mix up the fantasy epics and then
finally little finger my love little
finger but you got to admit he has tried
to pass himself off as sansas best
friend and has really been the opposite
so I think I can't imagine great things
going to happen to him Susan I've
actually written in my notes all caps
Littlefinger looking badder surge hora
por seguro I know what happened what's
interesting here you can kind of see him
like covering it up but he does look
increasingly worried it looks bad he's
got the grayscale infection which is
usually fatal unless you're the case of
Shireen Baratheon who manages to survive
yeah so if he manages to survive he
could turn into a stone man maybe but
it's high I don't know I'm not
particular fan of Sir Jorah I think he's
cool I like him I hope he's okay he'll
be sponsored your sausage look so when I
first saw this trailer I thought this
was reek it's actually ser Loras oh look
him because you can tell in the next
scene he is Marjorie giving him a hug so
that kind of goes to show that even
though Cersei managed to lie in wheedle
and get her way out of prison admittedly
a great embarrassment and cost the
Tyrells I haven't managed to do that
just yet where's Elena where
is where's the grandmother scheming
hopefully I think I kind of feel like
that characters one of the few
characters that can actually stand up
against Cersei so things stand up
against anybody she's badass lady um but
she needs to go rescue her grandchildren
pretty pretty quickly we have to fight
so so Davos we have to fight what does
he have in the background there zooming
in hand that is that is a stark banner
definitely as a stylist so this suggests
the Davos manages to get the stocks on
side and as we can see we've seen Santa
already proudly brandishing her stock
where it looks like they're in the same
place like snowy trees and cold probably
winter Polly just off to the left of
divorces is all sensor maybe she's cut
off underneath the horse here we are
we're actually at Winterfell so you can
see the burning crosses which means that
the Bolton armies there but those
structures off to the right that means
you're on Winterfell virus looking a bit
worried who's this lady yes so we know
from like the game of thrones casting
that she is another red priestess she
kind of looks like she's delivered some
bad news and that she's really happy
about it she's like seeing all this
stuff going on she's like mm-hmm just
FYI his uh his the worst thing that you
could have ever wondered BRB yeah you
can see I wonder away from so Tyrion and
Varys and manage I they're like the best
buddy cop movie I've ever seen that was
putting on my highlights through season
five was when they were traveling across
the Narrow Sea which is great so it's
interesting that they've been sort of
left in charge and that the Lord of
Light and his followers are just
determined to scan everywhere these days
any the old Lord of Light he's got
people everywhere dude all right from
son
so here here is pike let me rewind you
can't really tell again 720p some some
real CSI zoom in half come on Stephen
and hands this is pike this is the seat
of the the Greyjoy's I'm on this guy
here let me just do this you're on
Greyjoy so he plays a big role in the
books I don't want to spoil his story
too much he's not a particularly nice
guy and as we've seen from the casting
so in in the books he has like one eye
and he's kind of more piratey he
captain's a ship called the silence
where all the people who man the ship of
had their tongues oh he's not the nice
guy goes around raping and really a
marauding Greyjoy that isn't nice I've
never thought hey Yara's fine fine yarra
/ Asha will come to that but I do have
interesting stories about why he's
important and why the resurgence of Yara
is important our army here we've got
Jamie running through my Lannister turns
you can see the guy behind and
brandishing the Lannister colors some
kind of fight is going on that's like a
huge battalion camp of so rami we do
know from the fourth book um instead of
actually going to dawn he comes here
instead so it must be the Riverlands
here because the river Lords kind of
aren't bending the knee as much as they
should to the throne so Jamie sent up to
sort of bring them all into line and
actually one people that fights against
is catlins uncle Brynden more on that
later we got some fight scenes I think
we sent these the most exciting for me
and I'm going to go through slowly so
you can kind of see here this guy on the
left has a stark shield this guy on the
right once you get there that is a
Targaryen crest my friends this is a
flashback scene most likely from the
tower of joy you will not show up about
our joy oh I also won't show up a buck
Clegane bowl and I'll tell you four wide
a minute Tower of joy was a book
sequence I think it came in like a
flashback from
dead when he was like drunk on milk of
the poppy or something basically Ned's
sister Liana either absconded with or
got kidnapped by Rhaegar Targaryen whose
dinero sin veceras his dad and there was
a you know there was the whole Robert's
rebellion the battle of the north all
that happened and after that I'll die
down after the sack of King's Landing
Ned and a bunch of guys from the North a
bunch of his friends went down to try
and rescue Liana and she was at a place
called the Tower of joy this guy on the
right is probably Sir Arthur Dayne
remember the Kingsguard um who there's a
big big fight I won't spoil it but it's
kind of like this might be where we find
out who Jon Snow's mother is this
there's a big fan theory if you watch
last week next week's episode actually
by the time this goes out I dig into
this fan theory more um but if this is a
flashback scene where we finally get to
see what our joy lies you do notice as
well that he is wearing the exact same
helmet is the King's Kingsguard as well
hmm so I think you're pretty spot-on
there I hope soon but also Sir Arthur
Dayne he fights that big battle with two
swords so it's likely that he might just
take the sword from this guy he kills
this guy's probably what it like is one
of nets friends he goes with like six
buddies um to try and rescue his sister
and I think he's saying on he returns
risk kind of sad for Ned so here's
Tommen look at all grown up sir see you
can note here is wearing mark not
Marjorie mere sellers necklace so she
died she's only got one child left but
says he's obviously taking this to heart
yeah and it's gonna use it to fuel some
more revenge as if she needed more fuel
for that father so she needed anymore
but I do like her hmm she's watching
made her she made him the most of that
forced haircut this year she's rocking
the pixie our show them what the
Lannisters are so I she has got so much
like just revenge just ready to go I'm
really excited to see what she does
she's gonna kick them on its nest
so here I Coralie tell it looks like the
high Sparrow praying uh and someone's
kind of just creeping up on I actually
think this is a bit of a red herring
again I think this is what happens
before so I think this is jamie coming
up to talk to him and that's when they
have that confrontation yeah earlier in
the trailer I mean it does look at the
high spar in the same robes he's got 22
of his underlings guarding him so yeah
uh sir see what are you saying what do
you do to my enemies what do we do to
our enemies and then they've got this
amazing cutaway shot of someone stabbing
someone in the back I don't think the
high Sparrow would go down that easily I
think that someone else yeah and
actually I mean from the look of it
looks like a king's god helmet well I'm
thinking that might be a stretch but you
know I'm open to ideas I'm open to
interpretation that's a king's got
helmet that a large one or anything I'd
sir rob is strong uh and basically this
trailer is setting up the fact that
clicking balls gonna happen clicking
ball is where the mountain has been
resurrected by Kaiba and the Meister to
fight on behalf of Circe the Hound
didn't die despite dying off camera he
didn't die either and he's going to
represent the faith in a big battle for
the fate of Cersei Lannister so he's
been brought back and he's been referred
to as Sir Robert strong he's actually
the strongest man in the world the guy
who plays the mountain yeah so that's an
impressive dude you impressive so the
game ball do you think that'll be like
season six is giant moment like yeah oh
I think it was par with the stop here
we've got Yara Greyjoy and unnamed other
donor who that is he's not wearing an
eyepatch uh no that could be another
great that's likely to be another
Greyjoy but it's likely that she's gone
back to Pike there was a whole thing in
the book where she tries to become the
new head of the Ironborn like like
families chose to become a queen beside
Lee though they don't go for that
here we've got well first of all let's
just pay real close attention to me
Cyril who's wearing the floaty feathery
I love it so go Tyrells here and
Lannister troops obviously preparing
their troops are awesome yeah oh and
turns out there against the faith so I
think that's going to be one of the big
recurring themes is it says he's
determined to get revenge and basically
take control back from the faith and
she's going to use Jamie and his
position in which to do it if is the
Tyrells going up against them then I
guess they want the Tyrol co yeah
that'll be the only reason that's really
good they'll be the only reason the
Tyrells are going for is because they've
got Marjorie and Loras locked up tight
the real war is between the living and
the dead this is quite good they
actually show quite a lot of the other
night the night's king this is a really
interesting point to notice because
Davos so I mentioned earlier Davos and
Sansa teaming up so you can see Davos
here is at house mormont so like Jorah
Mormon but the thing is we actually find
out in I think series four or five that
the Mormons are only our bannermen to
the Starks and Lyanna Mormont who's like
this 10 year old girl who was in charge
of the whole house because you know
everyone keeps either dying or being
involved in the slave trade so she's in
charge of the house and when Stannis
rights to them to ask for the his
support she sends him a note saying Bear
Island knows no king but the King in the
north whose name is stark so if Davos
and Sansa team up and that's how they
get the Mormons on side to fight for
them that all ties together very that's
a very neat neatly with a bow so also
Sansa and Davos which is like dream team
I'm getting so excited about this year
someone getting I've let you just riddim
when I was someone getting bitch-slapped
we don't know who this is
but you can see the night's king doesn't
seem afraid of fire no which is worrying
because that was originally like the
only thing that would work against them
doesn't even fraid of fire and the
obsidian dagger dragonglass didn't work
either not looking so good nope for the
humans so here we have someone going
across the sea so I don't know I CT on
reddit someone said that like this could
be Sam being seasick I actually think
this is Sam finding out about the mutiny
which is quite sad and you can see Gilly
comforting him but Sam's on his way to
old town to train to become a maester
he's probably gonna blame himself
because he wasn't there to protect John
it's a zone fall he shouldn't never gone
here I'm gonna rewind a little bit not
because I don't know no so here we get
to see Yara Greyjoy and we know that
she's in volantis so this this lady is
lovely lady that she's making out with
has a tattoo on her cheek that is the
sign of a [ __ ] in volantis they are
made to get that tattoo so when your own
becomes king he wants your urine becomes
king well head of the Ironborn basically
he kind of once he wants dinero's his
dragons so he sort of sends people out
there so this kind of suggests that in
the show at least they've sent Yara or
she goes by herself to try and find an
heiress and get side tracked along the
way mm-hmm I mean who ya know in this
guy actually calls me quite a lot of
trouble to figure out who he was really
yeah because he's actually not that
obvious he's just an old guy but he's
actually the three-eyed crow so he is
the guy the brand keep seeing in all of
his dreams he's actually a legitimized
bastard etat illegitimate Targaryen
bastard son of egon the fourth so like a
long time goes actually very very old he
becomes the Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch and then one day he goes out
ranging beyond the wall and gets lost
and he's presumed dead a lot people get
lost up there it's pretty dangerous his
names are like Brynden rivers before
legitimize or he's also known as
bloodraven he's meant to have a big port
wine stain on his cheek like a birthmark
well you never know it could be hiding
behind his maze meant to be quite big
and it's meant to look like a raven last
words name blood great matter but he is
actually the guy who ends up teaching
bran about um by his gifts a warg skin
changing and green seeing which is um
being able to sort of use nature to see
like look into the past trying to drew
it yeah basically bronzer drew tormund
Giantsbane just five him but this who's
right so you see that flag is a house
hornwood who are the banner men of the
Starks so obviously Davos gets the
wildlings together with the dogs in that
battle but then that guy it's very
blurry guy blow a guy I'm just I can't
just point to every single man and say
he's likely to be a character who we
thought was dead but could be looks miss
Dennis asked I shall never die yeah he's
a guy with short hair it up flying a
different banner shush ah this is
obviously some battle Santa looking she
looks a bit worried there that's a shot
of oh we're kind of used to seeing that
yeah so here we've got um are you
fighting against the wave God Harrison
into a badass we got flip flip boom here
we have another battle a battle go we've
got Bolton banners this time around so
we've got the flayed man so this is
obviously one side of the siege and we
know who's on the other boom areas why's
dad like you said where is his dad Bruce
hasn't been around are you a truce the
thing is uh someone noticed on the
internet as always is the way there is
an ombre flag flying here really how
some bow so how samba actually you know
one bran and Rickon escaped hmm that's
where they went well that's why I reckon
when ah
makan wasn't was taken there by the
wildling lady Asha that's not it they
changed the names run from the book to
the TV show yeah I think we know you um
so he she was like she told to take him
to have somebody doing battles so Oh
quickly gone past it Cersei and probably
Jamie it looks like Jamie's hair and
build I guess wow she's a busy lady she
does have a certain affection for her
brother or her brother and as well like
if he had actually you know got an ID
done everything that she wanted she is
likely to repay that went him yes that's
that's how she likes to say thank you I
think uh here we've got the sons of the
harpy being more of a nuisance so it
looks like they're killing more masters
just being look at this could this also
be a flashback to see what happened to
wrap the rest of Daenerys his crew after
she was taken away by drogon yeah that
could be a this is where we left off in
murine a good point oh there's reclass
reek looks like he's being comforted
probably by Yara his sister other was I
imagine they'll meet again they didn't
meet again actually in the books so
right pod and Brienne so you know how is
all excited about Kyle game ball I'm
going to talk about it some more so in a
feast for crows Brienne and pod make
their way to the Riverlands to see the
Tully's you can see it's the tallies
because the the banner in the background
and brianna's on her mission to try and
find Sansa and when she's there she ends
up finding her way to the quiet Isle
which is like a world this morning this
monastery is and she meets a man named
the elder brother we already know that
ian mcshane is basically going to be the
elder brother because he kind of leaked
that himself like just paid no attention
to his NBA and there she sees a man who
could resemble the hound so highly
likely the hounds alive highly like the
mountains alive highly likely clicking
ball was going to highly likely game
but that's that's their story arc for
season six so here we have the mountain
just like totally ripping the face off a
member of the faith with his own chains
as well so clearly Circe's got him just
do today work for him drug on trogan
again Baggins do not do well in
captivity how do you know this that's
what I do I drink and I know things best
line of the trail best line so we know
that Daenerys is obviously out the
picture at least for the moment because
Tyrians drinking again um and I just
sort of love that she's got this small
Council who's just been I left to pick
up the pieces of a place that don't want
her or her friends cutter ragtags as
well that's all thinking teller at homes
um also one of them like is just a
translator in a city now that's quite
the promotion so but I will talk more
about this this kind of role that
Tyrians found himself in because it
looks like this sort of blended him with
another character from the book that
they've already said that they're not
putting in battle scene we've got some
banners solo banners potentially moment
um shields of our Bolton yeah flayed man
on the ship laid man on the shield so if
this is this big the battle of the
bastards I think it's or someone
referred to it online which I quite like
yeah wailings who's kidnapping pod I
unless let's rewind this didn't look
like no heart we can mean kind of see
his neck everyone is kind of saying this
could be brawn cuz of the gloves brawn
wes's yes that's very sure he does
whether like the fingerless finglas
numbers people wear gloves it's cold I
don't know he could be brought like 11
this is likely to be the giant 11 Giants
are great they were putting my favorite
things again a few they left but no
they're so great here is mirror ah so
she was the lady who was traveling with
bran and her brother who's another
greenseer whose name escapes me right
now but he was played by the guy from
love actually little kid from actually
that's his name now was the name but no
so we got mirror
she looks kind of worried I can't tell
if she's like climbing up from something
looks like something's above her kind of
about to ya do bad things whoo the thing
is you don't see who this is I'm
inclined to think this is Arya because
if she's blind she'll need to kind of
find her way around yes that's crimes it
doesn't look like a like a lady's hat
yeah um I'm inclined to think it's are
you title but don't worry but wait
there's more gonna stop it there oh damn
so you think you think teryn's good
terry is not gonna die no course not
tearing can't die yeah I will riot
george RR martin said that tyrion is
gonna be the one to basically last until
the end so he's never gonna be an auntie
peril but what's quite interesting is in
the book there's character called
Quentin Martel who is the son of Prince
Doran of Doran Martell off of dawn and
he sent all the way across the Narrow
Sea to find Daenerys Targaryen to bring
her to dawn Quentin sadly doesn't hate
this I mean this is actually quite you
know what happens he thinks that because
he's got a little bit of talk Harry and
blood in him that he can just ride a
dragon all the way back across to
Westeros um that does not happen no poor
poor naive in a man but it's interesting
to see what they've done with this shot
um you can kind of see his silhouette in
the flame yeah but I think I don't know
yeah signal live forever turn out live
and then
April 24th 9 p.m. on HBO well stream ln
h by now but we're in England can't do
that alright so that's everything that
you may have missed from the Game of
Thrones season 6 trailer number two they
fit so they snuck in a lot like I
watched it two or three times and until
I'd sat next you watching you pick apart
every frame it's quite amazing how much
they snuck in there I'm sorry I mean I
also kind of like it because they've
given out quite clear roadmap for how
six is going to go um which is a book
readers quite comforting um because
obviously they've deviated so much but
we'll find out more obviously when the
season premieres on april twenty fourth
for more on game of thrones make sure
you tune in the game spot of Thrones all
men must subscribe let's make sure to
follow us Dave I'm at a regular Dave I'm
a noose James games and we'll see you
next time
you
[Music]